Let'spickuponourcallerfromthe310areacode,
who'scallingtodayfrom310,mynameispresent.Heypresto!On,notonspeakerCarly.
No,no,Ijusttookitup.
Okay,soIhaveaquestion.Ifeelthatpoliticsisnotman.AhealthyaverageAmerican.Ifeellike
there'stoomuchtoomuchmoneythatisrunningthingsinthecountryiniteverypossibilitythat
moneygetstakenoutofpolitics,onlyifpeoplewhobenefitfrommoneybeinginpoliticsdecide
theywannagetitout.Andthisisthefundamentalconflictwe'realwaysupagainstthepeoplewho
areinpowergotinpowerwiththesystemwehave.
It'shardtogetintopowerifyoudon'thavethemoney,becauseeverybodyelseistakingthemoney.
Sowhatyoueventuallyendupwithisyou'rerelyingonpeoplewhobenefitedfromthemoney
beinginpoliticstotakeitoutandthat'salwaysadifficultthingbecauseoncepeoplehavepower,
theyarenottypicallyinclinedtochangethesystemthatgotthemthere.Soyes,moneycouldbe
removed.There'safewdifferentwaysthatitcoulddoit,itcouldbedone.Thefastestwaytodoit
dependsonwhoyouask,andwhatthepoliticalclimateiswho'sintheSupremeCourt?
There'saverygoodchancethatanyseriouschallengetomoneyinpolitics,wouldenduporsome
elementofitwouldendupgoingthroughtheSupremeCourt,ifTrumpgetsre­electedandthe
SupremeCourtgoes7­2withTrumpreplacingGinsbergwithaconservativejusticethatisa
massiveobstacletogettingmoneyoutofpolitics.Sowe'vegottothinksystemicallyaboutthis
stuff.Butyeah,unlessmoneyisoutofpolitics,thestatusquoperpetuatesmoneyinpoliticsand
moneyinpoliticsperpetuatesthestatusquo.
Thankyou,Iappreciatethat.
Alright,thankyouforcallingin,Iappreciateyourphonecall,Iapologize.I'mnotabletotakeany
03/06/20 Page12of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­06­commercialfree
morecallstoday.Idosee,we'vegot40orsopeopleholding...ButIdidthebestIgood.Wewill
takemorecallsagain,we'lltakeaquickbreak,andbebackrightafterthis.